Hey guys, I just watched this video and trust me,
you're going to want to stick around until the end. Also a reminder,
if you follow us on Instagram, you can guess who the mole is.
And we put the poll results in the video,
enjoy the episode and remember to vote.
How can you tell if someone is an American through their knowledge of American
history and political views, maybe it's by the type of food they eat.
Is it through their consumption of American pop culture and sports?
Or is it just by how they look? We brought together seven American.
I am an American. I'm an American, I'm an American, I'm an American.
I am an American.
I am an American one is a liar. If the group discovers who the liar is,
they'll win a cash prize. If the liar survives, they win the cash prize.
Oh,
and by American we're specifically talking about us citizens on this episode,
this is odd man out.
So something that makes me an American is I believe America is one of the
greatest countries in the world. I'm American, but by name only.
I was born in Hawaii.
So being American is like a totally different context to say, white,
CIS gendered. And those in Ohio, I was born in America.
I've always lived in America and I love my free time.
Lived here all my life. I've just lived the stereotypical American experience.
I'm related to spot the Lakers.
There is no one definition of what an American is.
I don't know why I'm so nervous. I'll try. I'm pretty confident.
I'm ready to win. I w I want the money.
I'm going to type out. H E S L.
Let's do it simple. Nice and sweet
on Warren. That was my first question.
Age, sex location, everything lines.
One is 30 and Alex is only 18.
And there's another person went from Hawaii. He's also has the same vote, uh,
like math on his emoji. So I met, like, I think maybe later I'm going to like,
be like, okay, maybe what are some Hawaii things you grew up with?
So that'd be interesting, I guess. I dunno,
naturalized as a baby at six weeks old.
Does that even a Kenyan mean naturalized as a baby.
Adopted. She just said that,
uh, uh, actually had that for lunch today too.
Oh, you're not talking to you. These are all really American chains.
They know doing other stuff. Buffalo, wild wings. Yeah.
Oh, Glen's parents are from Nigeria. My parents are actually from Nigeria.
Someone someone's going after Glen, Alex, there we go. 30 seconds.
Cause this a sauce. Like if they moved after then, you know,
these rounds are so short.
Okay. Well.
It seems like everyone is American.
So there's actually another person who's from Hawaii.
Sean, we kind of clicked. Cause we're both from Hawaii.
Tim is kind of on my list to be like, eh, I'm not. And get it right now.
Alex is coming from me. So I'll kind of give him like a little bit of actual.
Oh and who am I going to vote for this route? Oh.
I'm probably going to book for Alex.
I think I might vote out Glen for this round. Sophia.
Cause she was naturalized in six weeks. Sorry Glen. It just can't be me.
I think I'm going to vote for 10. I'm going to vote for Glenn.
I don't want to vote for Glenn, but I think that's what I'm going to go for.
It just cause I think some other people were gunning for him.
The person who eliminated this round is here. It goes.
Yeah. Eliminated. Sorry.
I'm pretty sorry. I'm really sorry. But I'm glad it wasn't me.
I knew the Nigeria stuff took me out.
So round two, this is the American meme route.
So we'll have four minutes to search the internet for the best
American meme you can find. Oh my God. Yes. I'm going to check tumbler.
Your time starts now.
I love memes. So I feel like I'll be good at it. Oh, not Trump.
That's too obvious.
I got to find something. That'll impress people.
I like all the news on Google. Like I don't want to,
I don't want them to think that I'm thinking like,
I think I'm going to go with turducken.
Oh wait, wait, where do you go?
Let's start with Sean.
I feel like Sean's name is stupid. Oh, it's Turkey.
Chicken.
You're not gonna lie, Sean. It's pretty like last year. All right.
Let's see what you got me on employee disagrees, caring. Oh God. You did. Okay.
That's a good one. That's a really good one.
Although I wouldn't say cared is like strictly American.
That was good. That was good. Mila. What's the male version of Karen.
Is it Keith?
Next up is Tim. [inaudible].
You call it people liking it. Okay. I was a little worried.
What can I say about this meme though? I don't know.
These memes are not a little dry, you know?
Oh, I didn't mean to put this in a political thing.
I thought it was funny though.
Dad jokes are my specialty.
Oh, okay. This is a touchy subject.
Are you afraid of white people becoming a minority?
Why are minorities created like second class citizens or something?
Bro. Shots fired.
I hope it was good enough, Sean. So.
She has someone order
that one's pretty good too.
I man, that's pretty American. It's a stereotype.
It's not funny. That's the thing like, come on. We all have funny ones. Like.
It must be indigenous people.
That must be tough. Ooh. Oh my goodness.
Oh no. Want you to hope for it? I really enjoyed this round. Um,
the memes were all right. They weren't as funny. They just made me kind of sad.
I'm not gonna lie. So the meme that I chose,
I tried to choose something that is like unequivocally without
a doubt. American who has had a turducken. I mean,
I could eliminate him just based off his knee. I think I might go with Mila.
She was very quiet this round. I don't know.
I kind of feel like this guy, Alex, he's kind of a, um, a caricature.
I'm not convinced Shawn. I'm gonna vote for Sean.
I'm gonna vote for Alex actually. Last minute change. Last minute change.
I'm voting for Alex.
I think I'm going to vote for Sean because a turducken is also Canadian.
I'm wanting to shine. Sorry, Sean. It just can't be me.
So the votes are in and the person eliminated this round
is Shaw.
I'm actually kind of shocked to be honest.
I don't know what I could have done differently. Yeah. you guys,
you guys eliminated an American. What is wrong with you?
Hey everyone. Hi.
What are you? Guys' favorite things about being American, I guess?
Um, yeah, I'm a very like big.
First amendment person. So that's good. Yeah.
I wouldn't say I'm very happy to be an American, to be honest.
And I, I actually know a lot of Americans also feel this way that it's like,
it's where I was born. It's where I was raised. But uh,
I have no real attachment. It doesn't feel like home. If that makes sense.
I'm a libertarian.
So I'm super into the first amendment and pretty much most of them.
Um, so freedom is the big thing. But as a libertarian right now is terrible.
Freedoms are being stripped dude. And I think people don't get this,
but libertarians do not like cops.
Like we're not just right-wingers or something. We do not like cops.
Hmm. I feel like because I'm adopted,
like I was growing up like, and I wanted to fit into that thing.
Like all my friends growing up or way,
like there was no diversity in my little town. I can sort of relate to that.
I'm not adopted,
but I grew up in a very white and so I can relate to wanting to
conform to something that you think is the ideal American.
And then when you get older,
you kind of realize there is no one definition of
being an American. And I agree with you there.
Cause like we're obviously not perfect right now. Um, but yeah,
like you're saying,
like we can definitely work towards things and that's like the,
one of the cool things that I enjoy about being American too,
is that we have the ability to change things like that as well.
I have families with ties and like the black Panthers and everything.
And I was never really, I wasn't taught to be proud to be American. I mean,
it is what it is. I feel like as Americans,
we should probably be proud of being ourselves first,
but then thing of course the individuality and we're all different and yeah.
Is everyone registered the boat?
Yes.
It doesn't require you to register actually. Oh yeah. I know
I haven't voted yet because I just turned 18, but uh,
definitely gonna vote in the election.
I honestly have no idea who is not American in this group. If anything.
Anything's a little harder.
Felt like we're still trying to feel each other out.
Think I'm going to vote for, um,
Sophia surely because she didn't talk as much.
I think I'm just going to vote for Alex because he's the most aggressive this
round.
I think I'm going to vote for Alex because he seems like the most likely to be
the mole to me. I think I'm going to have to go with Lynn. Actually.
I just asked if I could change my vote. I feel bad,
but I feel like she didn't give a lot of information in the beginning. I think.
I'm going to vote for some here this round. I still got my eyes on you Mila,
but I'm thinking and so the, uh.
No,
the votes are in and the person eliminated this round
is Sophia.
I played myself with my vote. Like if I had kept it with Alex,
like would he have had other votes? They just knew.
They just knew that I was American. So they had to vote me out.
Hey guys, again, I have.
A question. I have a question, Alex, how were you?
The one that knew the turducken was from Canada.
Yeah,
because I have a lot of Canadian friends and they always went back to their
homes to do turducken,
but I've never had a Thanksgiving with terduk and we just do Turkey.
I've I've heard that like people in America do,
but I think it's more North near, near Canada.
I'm guessing I've only been to Canada once,
so I don't have that much information on it, but yeah.
We'll have a lot of Canadian friends.
Uh, DC man. There's a lot of international schools around, you know,
there's waste there's yeah.
Quick question. Quick question. Yeah. Okay. Tim and Alex,
you both have been to DC and you know, the.
DC area, right?
Relative. I've lived there a couple of years.
How do you and you claim that there are diplomats children there, right?
How can you prove that you are not one of them?
I've uh, I've lived there for 18 years. Um,
and I didn't really live in somewhere where a diplomats live.
Although I knew them because I feel like they're more Northwest. Uh,
and I was more like central, I guess, like downtown, uh, near,
near Georgetown.
Yeah. So I didn't actually live in DC. I just, my dad worked there. Uh,
we lived in Virginia, so he would commute up there a lot. Like most people do.
Whereabouts in Virginia, like Arlington I'm guessing. Right.
Uh, I actually lived in Stafford. It's like right by Fredericksburg, you know,
that is 30 minutes away. So yeah, he would commute up there. So yeah,
I'd been to the DC area quite a bit. Well, I lived there for a few years. Um.
I'm going to vote out Alex.
He was just trying to like prove himself a little too much. That's all.
I think Alex is pretty safe on me. I think Mila is a little more successive.
Me and Alex. I think the girls are siting together.
I think the guys decided together, but this is just turning into,
I think I'm going to go with Mila.
I am still most suspicious of Alex.
I don't know if that round went as well as the last one.
I felt kind of attacked. Yeah. I'm going to vote off Mila because um,
I think what she's doing is deflecting from.
The votes are in and we have a tie.
What the tie is between Alex and Mila.
So you're going to have 20 seconds to prove to us why you're embarrassed.
Okay. This is wild because I don't even care for being an American,
but it is what it is.
My family is generations from the same area in California,
literally from Mississippi. Uh, I don't like, I don't know what else to say.
That is my, I was born and raised in America.
I know what time.
I was born in DC, raised in DC Sibley hospital. That's where I'm born. Uh,
I've got an American flag right there, but I cannot show you that.
I don't think, um,
I don't think you find many libertarians outside of the U S I think is pretty
pro you know, American. Um, and I know a lot of international people because my,
my parents worked for the government.
That's why you've got Virginia and New York coming together.
Um, I feel like because I was onto them, they're threatened.
So now they're just like what to vote her out.
Hopefully they've got my back and I am, and they won't vote me out.
I'm an American, I promise.
We got to know more about you other than your libertarian, who was born in.
I don't, I'm not really suspicious of anybody. I know for a fact,
Lynn's not going to change her answer.
And Alex and I don't want to do to Alex and dirty like that either. Um.
The votes are in and the person eliminated on round four
is Alex. Um.
Uh, it's a shame. I'm not going to get my money. Nina is on her game though.
Got to give her that.
Thumbs up on zoom. If you want to continue to gain, if not,
you think you've covered them all and want to end the game right now,
if the color that shows up behind me is green. You all win.
If it's red, the mole is still in the game and you lost.
And sweaty.
In three, two, one.
[Inaudible].
The mall can raise your hand and reveal him or herself in three,
two, one.
I knew
[inaudible]. I voted for Alex for like the past three rounds. I know.
You are 100%, right?
I'm not American.
I believe we got him.
We got him all my God.
That last round was just so important that tie,
if that tie had not have happened, we would've lost.
I memorized the pledge of allegiance.
I should have asked someone to recite that.
I'm really upset. I'll probably regret it forever.
The cast is pretty diverse. They'll have really good perspectives.
It was a lot that goes down.
What makes someone American being willing to share your culture with others and
also accepting of other cultures that are here.
I love Americans, honestly. I think it has great principals, great values,
even though those values might not necessarily be in practice right now.
I think Americans the greatest, but obviously not everyone.
You know, I sure felt American when we won.
I that's the only time I felt American when we won. Oh yeah.
That's the most American I ever felt in my life.